if i go to the grocery store can i eat
food from there sure that it's not
genetically modified you can okay but
what i usually tell people and i think a
lot of people hear it don't shop in them
inside out house that's where you should
not be because that's where most of the
processed food lies
shop on the corners shop on the outside
walls where you have your vegetables and
fruits and vegetables and meats in your
dairies and whatever
but you know i don't
very little of my consumption comes from
the supermarkets anymore but i've been
doing this for a while and how i was
raised is this i don't like
you you go into a supermarket now it
looks like a cartoon world
think about that yes go walk up but you
can go film it and then go back and
watch the film as you walk down the
aisles how many colors how many
animation pictures do you see
how much manipulation is being fed into
your brains like oh heart healthy and
it's got a you know a wonderful picture
and somebody's very happy and in peace
and you know think about the
manipulation that goes on with marketing
advertising injecting chemicals into
your food supply and you are the person
who gets to recycle every bit of it from
audio to video to the food itself
you are the test subject and they make
you feel good about it because it tastes
good i'm actually shocked that cancer
culture made its way into the grocery
store and they started to cancel some
people uh who were on the boxes right
but that that happened um so
you go to the grocery store i think a
lot of people here say all right cool i
got it i went last night
screwed up yeah
what do you do when you go you shop
around the edges of the grocery store
you avoid the middle uh what does a
normal diet look like like when you say
that uh hey i'm not gonna give health
advice right everyone's body is
different right but how do you think
about putting body uh food in your body
when you're traveling and not at home
right
i look the source of the seed of my
nutrition is pure animal protein it's
that simple but you know
that's how i was raised we were raised
with we had a freezer full of beef at
any time you had market access to that
beef five years old i'm cooking
hamburgers from a local rancher right or
from grandfather or whatever and so that
is the source of the seed of basically
how i look at food right now especially
in the united states of america it's
like yesterday i went and i got in flew
in and then i went to publix which you
know it's it's a it's a good store you
know there's there's a lot of things
that are good about it and there's a lot
of things that are bad i went straight
to the meat section i bought some
hamburger meat grass-fed i know it
probably probably isn't grass fed but
it's as close to it as i can find got it
so it's not a black and white issue here
there's so much gray and so i buy that
beef bought a steak bought hamburgers i
went to uh the beachfront i cooked the
steak and hamburgers i ate the
hamburgers last night took me less than
30 minutes same amount of time as people
sit in the freaking drive-through at
mcdonald's and here i ate burgers last
night and i had a steak for breakfast i
won't have to eat again
probably until late tonight if i if i
don't want to
by eliminating all my i think that i
have all these options i don't give
myself options yeah and so when you go
and you're looking at uh kind of the
meat counter if you will right and they
say hey what do you want right are there
things that you will avoid in uh in
there in terms of selecting the meat at
the grocery store and things that you
will go so you mentioned grass fed uh
like almost give people like what's the
framework right if they're gonna go and
they're gonna get meat at the grocery
store what should they be thinking about
what are the things that they should
avoid
one thing you know you used to you could
go to and you'd they'd have a butcher
right
well those don't you know that that
doesn't exist and so a lot of grocery
stores won't even know where the beef
comes from they they can't tell you
because they actually they have that you
know that wholesale market that i talked
about earlier so you don't really know
the butchers don't know and so i don't
eat supermarket beef but i know a lot of
people have to so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to pay a little extra for
it because that's one thing that you
should you know if you're going to use
that retail market through a supermarket
you should basically look for the grass
fed look for the organic because it's
it's better than that crap beef that
they they're probably giving you
and that crab beef like i said it could
be from africa it could be from brazil
it can breed from texas but you're not
going to know and the people that are
basically selling you they're not going
to know either
and so if you can eliminate some of
those deceptions
then just drill down as close as you can
and you sh you're going to be okay hey
you did you like this video great make
sure you subscribe like the video and
see you next time